les compressions chez rona cette année
qui appartient au groupe américain
lowe's ont provoqué de vives réactions
plusieurs se questionnent sur l'avenir
de la quincaillerie au québec dans ce
contexte devant la chambre de commerce
du montréal métropolitain cette semaine
le patron du groupe bmr et déclaré que
son entreprise est là pour rester pascal
houle et le chef de la direction du
groupe bmr bonsoir bus rouleront suffire
est-ce que ça va bien la quincaillerie
au québec parce qu'on parle beaucoup de
rhône-alpes des difficultés de rona vous
comment vous vivez marché présentement
je vous ai chez nous ça va très très
bien et les ventes sont en croissance
nos marchés nos marchands propriétaires
qui sont en sont en développement
en effet deux acquisitions au courant de
l'année on a développé de nouveaux
concepts de magasins avec des magasins
la chope ici à montréal à gauche
unitaire n'avait de montréal ont des
tendances en développement nos ventes de
doivent de marcher d'un marchand
l'ontario et pour nous tout va bien dans
cette impulsion vient du marché ou
vient-elle plus de l'acquisition de la
coop fédérée il ya quelques années qui
est maintenant propriétaire du groupe b
je voudrais il ya plusieurs aspects où
il le fait d'être propriété n'obteniez
qu'actionnaire la cua fédérer ça nous
donne les ressources en eau des
ressources financières
ça nous donne aussi l'intérêt de
demeurer ici ça donne confiance en nos
marchands et non marchands et des
marchands propriétaires qui sont
impliqués dans leur milieu qui
travaillent dans leur magasin avec le
fait d'avoir un propriétaire qui est au
québec qui l'on pourrait citer celui là
donc confiance à nos marchands en se
cachant pas que l'économie bonne aussi
dans la dernière année dans l'analyse
dernières années l'économie est
excellente pour mon marchand la
construction est bonne la rénovation est
bonne fac ça ça donne de bons résultats
qu'est ce que vous faites de différent
parce qu'on a reçu des marchands
propriétaires de renault qui sont venus
ici pour dire nous aussi on est connecté
sur le québec qui nous sommes des
québécois puis même si c'est l'autre qui
est propriétaire de renault maintenant
on est connecté qu'est ce que vous
faites de différent vous je voudrais on
a entamé un programme un virage
numérique on si on entend beaucoup
parler on attendait des géants du
numérique de chamonix et amazon de ce
monde
nous on fait un virage clic est
mortifiée que ça veut dire qu'on veut
s'assurer d'être très très très efficace
une bonne note virage numérique au
niveau des ventes ou m
on veut s'assurer de s'ajuster au
comportement du consommateur avant le
meilleur service possible en magasin qui
est donnée par nos marchands
propriétaires qu'on voit vraiment allié
le service un magasin le consommateur y
ait encore besoin de se faire servir un
magasin de toucher aux produits d'avoir
un bon cv si un client tel mond une
profondeur de produits avec avec le
numérique mais home depot a investi plus
de 5 milliards dans son vin village
d'amérique dans votre discours cette
semaine 1 chambre de commerce je dirais
qu'en 2016 amazon hausse de 35% des
ventes de produits de quincaillerie
comment on se bat contre amazon on se
bat avec un serveur sa clientèle vous
savez amazon a commencé là numérique
n'est aujourd'hui investie d'une brique
et mortier nous on est déjà dans une
brique et mortier on est dans plus de
200 ch 35 municipalités au québec
alors on est déjà cette présence là pour
offrir le conseil le produit à aux
consommateurs elle nous par contre on a
commencé que les briques et mortier mais
aujourd'hui on est du numérique et on
fait des commandes en ligne on est sur
le web qui on est on fait du commerce a
mis canal le consommateur peut ni
récupérer son prix en magasin vous êtes
québécois ben vos produits sont-ils
québécois à quelle hauteur je voudrais
on s'en faire de voir 75% des produits
chez nous convainc son de fournisseurs
québécois 90 offre aux québécois dont
ils peuvent importer de l'étranger mais
c'est des fournisseurs qui avaient signé
fournisseurs on encourage fournisseurs
condorcet h à salle ici qui ont des
employés d'iss effectivement c'est sûr
qu'il ya certains produits qu'ils
vendent hysteria mais ses défenseurs qui
ont ch à saly 6 90% du produit vient de
fournisseurs canadiens vous avez dit
cette semaine l'an passé nous avons
accueilli un nombre record de nouveaux
marchands de rona bonne serment de
renault de l'ensemble des manières de la
compétition on acquis 30 nouveaux
marchands au québec en ontario dans les
maritimes qui provient de différents
d'année à 30 nouveaux marchands combien
de rona l'année passée voudrait une
dizaine d'euros nord les dernières
années et compte tenu de ce qui se passe
présentement chez rona décompression des
inquiétudes est-ce que des marchands
présentement rona qui vous parle on peut
vous cachera pas qu'on a des discussions
que certains marchands vont non non on a
des contraintes de marché ont fait
respecter les territoires on est
vraiment raison d'être est très présent
québec pour nous l'important c'est est
respectée non marchands bmr actuellement
démarche en avant l'action des jours ci
contre avec la bannière fait que s'il
faut respecter tous ces enjeux long mais
est-ce que vous les invités à venir chez
vous c'est certain qu'on dit yvette
année chez nous on est un joueur
québécois on est un joueur qui est basé
ici notre siège social est ici à
boucherville
même chose pour la coop fédérée kenna
tunein actionnaires alors nous on est
ici pour rester
vous avez l'été dernier fait
l'acquisition de parts dans le groupe
lefebvre et benoît un qui est ce que
vous avez comme ça d'autres acquisitions
en vue ce soit en a plusieurs
principalement avec le fameux benoît
c'est un marché dans lequel on n'était
pas présents toute la vente de matériaux
de construction commerciale au niveau du
multi logements
on n'était pas présent ni à montréal ni
à toronto dont partenaires dans la
sphère des manoirs sont présents alors
ça va faire partie de notre stratégie de
développement tant au québec qu'en
ontario de faire d'autres acquisitions
avec nos partenaires
vous avez acheté des parents chez
lefebvre rue benoit vous n'êtes pas le
propriétaire majoritaire de lefeuvre on
a acheté des parts on est partenaire
avec les partenaires que je suis vous
augmentez vos parts dans ce groupe leur
ca pourrait éventuellement on a plein de
projets dans nos plans de projets
d'acquisitions et vous avez des projets
pour l'ontario oui on est au service de
marché de 16 milliards qu'ont récemment
que le marché de québec était de finir
on ne peut plus l'innovation la
rénovation plaques et kerry de détails
ok alors on pourrait être plus présent
des dix semaines on est dix magasins
présentement l'ontario on est des
projets de croissance tant goût du
détail avec des marchés avec des
magasins bea mer que dans le volet
commercial avec les jeunes la favb à
noidans grande région de toronto
à un certain moment que vous l'avez dit
aussi dans votre discours vous êtes posé
la question s'il fallait continuer dans
les magasins physiques
vous avez décidé de continuer dans les
magasins fioul de 10 sites de contenus
dans les magasins physiques le
consommateur recherche est présence leur
richesse recherche au service et on doit
s'assurer aussi des clones en stratégie
numérique le consommateur fait dh aux
frais du prêt à chaud est encore besoin
de venir au magasin
le consommateur veut avoir le choix et
vous avez la main d'oeuvre et on a la
main d'oeuvre ont très peur on manque
pas de médor on sait que plusieurs non
marchand ont connu certains les enjeux
comme toutes les entreprises n'ont
réussi à tirer notre épingle du jeu ont
réussi à garder nos employés ont réussi
à attirer des employés effectivement on
vit des moments plus difficiles
vous savez la crise élevé qu'ailleurs je
voudrais nos salaires sont compétitifs
par rapport au marché
pascal houle merci beaucoup vous êtes le
chef de la direction du groupe bmr merci
beaucoup merci merci bien